yeah I mean historically if you think
about the
impact um of Aristotle's Works becoming
available within like a set of decades
right in a already
literate uh
milu it's um it's pretty massive I mean
they had Cicero a lot of his Works they
had Sona they had August buus you know
big Heavy Hitters like that um they
weren't they didn't have a lot of
PL uh until the Renaissance um so he's
not really on the scene but they know
about Plato you know and then suddenly
you get your hands on this and there's
also like learned Arab commentaries
and um at least a couple really
important Greek commentators that are
available too like Alexander of
aphrodisius who interestingly so
Aristotle gets called the philosopher
Alexander is called the commentator you
know I I actually have I don't know did
I ever tell you guys about this I have a
uh essay in the Journal of hot takes
which is kind of a joking project put
together which claims that Plutarch is a
better platonist than Plato is and
Alexander of aphrodisius is a better
Aristotelian than Aristotle is and part
of the reason is because um they they
are coming later so they're able to like
think through um what the great
philosopher did and what they didn't do
and they're able to do that in relation
to the other schools that have
subsequently developed right so
Aristotle can't address the stoics
because they didn't exist in his time
Alexander of apodius they've you know
the stoics have been around
for uh about 300 years making arguments
why the Aristo have things wrong right
so he can say yeah the stoic say this
and here's why they're wrong you know
here's how an aristan would respond
which I think is pretty cool you know
but there is another sort of like
secondary phenomenon that was very
common from about the 19 century onward
and I still I think still has a lot of
sway which is basically you know you got
the presocratic and they're kind of
screwing around figuring things out but
they're you know they're smart but
dummies right and then we get Socrates
coming on the scene and Plato his uh
really his only important student you
know and Plato develops this wonderful
metaphysics that you know we're not
quite sure exactly if it's coherent but
sure is fun to read you know and he's
pretty brilliant uh and then he's got a
student Aristotle and Aristotle moves
from idealism to
empiricism and actually looks at the
world and you know that's that's a good
thing too and so you know he's we've got
these two great philosophers and the the
two great systems and then after that
it's just kind of downhill until we get
to platinus you know because platinus is
is is good but all this stoic and
skeptic and epicurian and you know later
plate it's all just kind of derivative
nonsense you know and you know if you
look at um if you look at the history of
this this developed among first among
the Germans in the 19th century and it's
also tied in with this idea that um the
Greek city state declined and became
just a part of an Empire right Alexander
and the successor Kingdom and then the
Roman
Empire and that that like led to less
Innovation less creativity you know less
um tackling big projects and more
focusing on how to make your shitty life
not so so bad you know the way the
stoics and the Skeptics and the Epic
carians did
and so Hegel says this and then you know
popularizers like vindel Bond will say
this and Scholars like joerger will will
make these claims and then it it becomes
like the the the standard take right if
you're an educated person you just know
this is this is the take right and so
then you don't bother to read the
ancient uh helenistic philosophy or if
you do you read it um kind of sloppily
right because you already know that
Plato and Aristotle are the only game in
town and and I think this appealed to
the Catholic um Toms because you know
tomis becomes like a big concern after
attorney poess in the late 19th century
and then it like takes over everywhere
and it fits this really neat nice
narrative where um Plato and Aristotle
right and then Augustine and
aquinus pl's the or yeah uh Augustine is
a platonist aquinus is is an Aristo
and you know everything got solved by by
aquinus so you got the more
secular um academic philosophers doing
it over here and then you've got you
know uh the Tomas doing it over here and
it becomes just like something that we
all know and it gets its way into like
philosophy textbooks so then you get um
philosophy you know began with the
presocratic then it's Plato and
Aristotle a bunch of bunch of crap then
we get you know the Middle Ages and they
they like to talk about Arguments for
the existence of God and so we'll put in
a chapter about that and then you know
there's this thing called the
Renaissance but we're not going to read
any of those people uh and then we get
to modern philosophy now we get dayart
and maybe Thomas hops or bacon and now
philosophy begins again right and when
you look at this stuff you're like well
who the hell actually was dumb enough to
buy this line you know and that the
answer is some really really smart
people who got them themselves convinced
of it and and it's still like the
standard take in a lot of places down to
the present unfortunately I think the
last 50 years there's been a lot of good
academic work done on um helenistic and
and Roman philosophy and and on you know
better medieval stuff so it's not just
well there was this guy Austine and then
you know there was buus and there's this
weirdo aragen and then uh anom abalar
Thomas aquinus then it all went to crap
with scotus and and aam you know there's
there's a wider uh range of of reading
of these Scholastics which is which is
good um but it's still a minority
viewpoint